p
私は、
おとぎ話が TA によって噴水から作られた TIG をキャッチすると信じています、ああ、私は勝つと信じています、喜びへの
道を私が落ちることは明らかです、そしてああ、
神の
夜、私たちは一緒にいます、ああ、あなたの
恐怖を生きたままにしておき、あなたの恐怖を忘れて、
あなたの恐怖を忘れてください。
あなたのGUになることを夢見ています、
あなたが
そこから出てくるのがわかります、私は再び立ち上がるのを待っています、私の血の中にそれを感じることが
できます、私は手にフレを持っています、
再びWを上げます、私の血の中でそれを感じることができます、
私は私の中にフレを保持しています
待ちから再び上へ手を伝える 私は
それを血の中に感じることができる 私は未来を手に持つ
W から再び上へ 私はそれを感じることができます
未来を手に持つ
待ちから再び上へ 感じることができる
それは私の血の中にある、
私は未来を手にしている、私は
再び立ち上がるのを待っているのではなく、私の血の中でそれを感じることができる、私は手に未来を抱いている、秋からではない、私は再び立ち上がるのを待っている
それを私の血の中で感じることができる 私はMの中に未来を抱いている
秋から
再び立ち上がるのを待っているのではなく、私の中でそれを感じることができる 私は心に未来を抱いている
再び立ち上がるのを待っているのではなく、私の中でそれを感じることができる
血をもう一度感じて、
未来を感じて、
また感じて、また
待っている
から、
また立ち上がるのを待っているから、恐怖はその
ままに
して、
夢を
見させてG
おとぎ話とセレンディップの出会いを信じます
ああ、おとぎ話と出会いを信じます